La petite Shannon -- vous la voyez là à gauche --
se porte beaucoup mieux maintenant,
et Ryan a obtenu un emploi en suivant certains de nos cours.
Qu'est-ce qui rendait donc ces cours si différents ?
Après tout, les contenus des cours en ligne étaient disponibles depuis un certain temps.
Ce qui les rendait différents, c'est qu'il s'agissait de véritables cours.
Tout a commencé un beau jour,
et les étudiants se sont mis à regarder des vidéos sur une base hebdomadaire
et faisaient les devoirs.
Et c'étaient de vrais devoirs
pour une vraie note, avec une vraie échéance.
Vous pouvez voir les délais et le graphique d'utilisation.
Voici les pics qui montrent
que la procrastination est un phénomène mondial.
(Rires)
À la fin du cours,
les élèves ont obtenu un certificat.
Ils pouvaient présenter ce certificat
à un employeur éventuel et obtenir un meilleur emploi,
et nous connaissons beaucoup d'étudiants qui l'ont fait.
Certains élèves ont pris leur certificat
et l'ont présenté à un établissement d'enseignement où ils étaient inscrits
pour obtenir une vraie validation.
Ces étudiants obtenaient quelque chose de vraiment significatif
pour le temps et les efforts qu'ils avaient investis.
Parlons un peu de certaines composantes
qui entrent dans ces cours.
Le premier élément est que, en vous éloignant
des contraintes d'une vraie classe
et en concevant des contenus dédiés à un format en ligne,
vous pouvez vous affranchir, par exemple,
du cours magistral monolithique d'une heure.
Vous pouvez diviser votre contenu, par exemple,
en modules courts de 8 à 12 minutes,
chacun représentant un concept cohérent.
Les étudiants peuvent parcourir ce contenu de différentes manières,
selon leurs acquis, leurs compétences ou leurs intérêts.
Par exemple, certains étudiants pourraient bénéficier
d'un peu de contenu préparatoire
que d'autres étudiants pourraient déjà avoir.
D'autres étudiants pourraient être intéressés
par un sujet particulier qu'ils voudraient étudier seuls plus en profondeur.
Ce format nous permet donc d'en finir
avec un enseignement uniformisé,
et permet aux étudiants de suivre un cursus bien plus personnalisé.
Bien sûr, nous savons tous en tant qu'enseignants
que les étudiants n'apprennent pas en restant assis et en regardant passivement des vidéos.
Une des composantes les plus importantes de cet effort
est peut-être qu'il faut que nos étudiants
s'exercent avec le contenu des cours
afin de vraiment les comprendre.
Une série d'études en a démontré l'importance...
Par exemple, celle-ci est parue dans Science l'an dernier,
et montre que même la simple pratique de reconstitution,
dans laquelle les étudiants répètent censément
ce qu'ils ont préalablement appris
donne des résultats considérablement meilleurs
dans les divers tests de fin de parcours
que de nombreuses autres techniques.
Nous avons essayé d'intégrer la pratique de reconstitution dans la plate-forme,
ainsi que d'autres types d'entraînement de différentes manières.
Par exemple, même nos vidéos ne sont pas que des vidéos.
La vidéo s'interrompt régulièrement après quelques minutes
et on pose une question aux étudiants.
(Vidéo) SP : ... Ces quatre choses. La théorie des perspectives, l'actualisation hyperbolique,
le biais de statu quo, l'oubli de la fréquence de base. Elles sont toutes bien documentées.
Ce sont toutes des déviations bien documentées du comportement rationnel.
DK : La vidéo s'interrompt ici,
et l'étudiant tape la réponse dans le cadre
et la soumet. Évidemment, il n'était pas attentif.
(Rires)
Alors il doit essayer à nouveau,
et cette fois, il ne se trompe pas.
Il y a une explication s'il veut.
Et maintenant la vidéo passe à la partie suivante du cours.
C'est une question simple
qu'en tant que professeur je pourrais poser en classe,
mais quand je pose ce genre de question en classe,
80 % des étudiants
sont encore en train de griffonner ce que je viens de dire,
15 % sont scotchés sur Facebook,
et puis il y a Monsieur Je-sais-tout au premier rang
qui laisse échapper la réponse
avant que quelqu'un d'autre ait pu y réfléchir,
et en tant que professeur je suis terriblement heureuse
que quelqu'un connaisse vraiment la réponse.
Et le cours continue, avant même
que la plupart des étudiants aient remarqué qu'on avait posé une question.
Ici, chaque étudiant
doit s'investir dans le contenu.
Et bien sûr ces simples questions de reconstitution
ne sont pas la fin de l'histoire.
Il faut incorporer beaucoup plus de questions d'entraînement significatives,
et il faut aussi fournir aux étudiants un retour
sur ces questions.
Comment évaluer le travail de 100 000 étudiants
si vous n'avez pas 10 000 assistants d'éducation ?
La réponse est, vous avez besoin d'utiliser la technologie
pour qu'elle le fasse pour vous.
Heureusement, la technologie a bien évolué,
et nous pouvons maintenant évaluer plusieurs types intéressants de devoirs.
En plus des QCM
et de questions brèves comme vous avez vu dans la vidéo,
nous pouvons également évaluer les maths, les expressions mathématiques
ainsi que les dérivations mathématiques.
Nous pouvons évaluer des modèles, qu'il s'agisse
de modèles financiers dans un cours d'économie
ou de modèles physiques dans un cours de sciences ou de génie
et nous pouvons évaluer certains devoirs de programmation assez sophistiqués.
Je vais vous en montrer un qui est en fait assez simple
mais assez visuel.
C'est tiré du cours d'informatique pour débutants de Stanford,
et les étudiants sont censés corriger la couleur
de cette image rouge floue.
Ils tapent leur programme dans le navigateur,
et vous pouvez voir que ce n'est pas tout à fait juste, que la stature de la Liberté a toujours le mal de mer.
Et donc, l'étudiant essaie encore et maintenant il a réussi, et on le lui dit,
et il peut passer à la tâche suivante.
Cette possibilité d'interagir activement avec le contenu
et de savoir si sa réponse est juste ou fausse
est vraiment essentielle à l'apprentissage des étudiants.
Bien sûr nous ne pouvons pas encore évaluer
entièrement le travail qu'il faut fournir pour tous les cours.
Plus précisément, ce qui manque, c'est le travail qui demande une pensée critique
qui est tellement essentiel dans des disciplines
comme les sciences humaines, les sciences sociales, l'économie et d'autres.
Donc nous avons essayé de convaincre, par exemple,
certains de nos professeurs de sciences humaines
que le QCM n'était pas une si mauvaise stratégie.
Ça n'a pas été très bien reçu.
Nous avons dû trouver une solution différente.
Et la solution que nous avons fini par utiliser est l'évaluation par les pairs.
Il s'avère que la série d'études de tout à l'heure montre,
comme celle-ci par Saddler et Good,
que l'évaluation par les pairs est une stratégie étonnamment efficace
pour fournir des évaluations reproductibles.
On l'a essayée seulement avec des petites classes,
mais ça a montré, par exemple,
que ces notes attribuées par des étudiants sur l'axe des y
sont en fait très bien corrélées
avec les notes attribuées par l'enseignant sur l'axe des x.
Plus surprenant encore, les auto-évaluations,
où les étudiants notent leur propre travail de façon critique --
du moment que vous les motivez à le faire correctement
pour qu'ils ne s'attribuent pas une note parfaite --
sont en fait encore mieux corrélées avec les notes de l'enseignant.
C'est donc une stratégie efficace
qu'on peut utiliser pour noter à l'échelle,
et c'est aussi une stratégie d'apprentissage utile pour les étudiants,
parce qu'en fait ils apprennent par l'expérience.
Nous avons maintenant le plus grand circuit de notation par les pairs jamais conçu,
où des dizaines de milliers d'étudiants
notent mutuellement leurs travaux,
et je dois dire que ça fonctionne bien.
Mais ça ne s'arrête pas à des étudiants assis tout seuls
dans leur salon à travailler sur des problèmes.
Autour de chacun de nos cours,
une communauté d'étudiants s'est formée,
une communauté mondiale de gens
autour d'un effort intellectuel commun.
Ce que vous voyez là est une carte auto-générée
par des étudiants de notre cours de sociologie pour débutants de Princeton
où ils doivent se mettre sur une carte du monde,
et vous voyez vraiment l'étendue mondiale de ce genre d'effort.
Les étudiants collaborent dans ces cours de bien des façons.
Tout d'abord, on a créé un forum de questions - réponses
où les étudiants posaient des questions,
et d'autres étudiants y répondaient.
Ce qui est vraiement stupéfiant,
c'est qu'il y avait tellement d'étudiants,
que même si un étudiant posait une question
à 3 heures du matin,
quelque part dans le monde,
il y avait quelqu'un éveillé
qui travaillait sur le même problème.
Dans beaucoup de nos cours,
le temps de réponse médian pour une question
sur le forum était de 22 minutes.
C'est un niveau de service que je n'ai jamais offert à mes étudiants de Stanford.
(Rires)
Et vous voyez d'après les témoignages des étudiants
qu'en fait ils trouvent
que grâce à cette grande communauté en ligne,
ils interagissent entre eux de bien des façons
qui sont plus profondes que quand ils le faisaient dans le contexte d'une vraie classe.
Les étudiants se rassemblaient,
sans aucune intervention de notre part,
en petits groupes d'étude.
Certains étaient des groupes d'étude physiques,
en fonction des contraintes géographiques
et se rencontraient chaque semaine pour travailler sur un ensemble de problèmes.
Voici le groupe d'étude de San Francisco,
mais il y en avait dans le monde enteir.
D'autres étaient des groupes d'étude virtuels,
parfois en fonction de la langue ou selon des critères culturels.
En bas à gauche,
vous voyez notre groupe d'étude universel et multiculturel
où les gens voulaient explicitement entrer en relation
avec des gens d'autres cultures.
Il y a des possibilités énormes
à tirer de ce type de cadre de travail.
La première est que ça peut nous donner
une vision totalement nouvelle
de l'apprentissage humain.
Parce que les données que nous pouvons collecter sont uniques.
On peut collecter chaque clic, chaque travail soumis,
tous les posts des dizaines de milliers d'étudiants sur le forum.
On peut alors étudier l'apprentissage humain
non plus à partir d'hypothèses
mais à partir de données, cette transformation,
par exemple, a révolutionné la biologie.
On peut utiliser ces données pour comprendre des questions fondamentales
comme, quelles sont les bonnes stratégies d'apprentissage
qui sont efficaces et celles qui ne le sont pas ?
Dans un cours précis,
on peut se poser des questions
comme, quelles sont les erreurs les plus communes
et comment aider les étudiants à y remédier ?
Voici un exemple
également tiré du cours d'apprentissage automatique d'Andrew.
C'est une distribution de mauvaises réponses
à un des exercices d'Andrew.
Les réponses se trouvent être des paires de nombres,
on peut donc les représenter sur un graphique en deux dimensions.
Chaque petite croix que vous voyez est une mauvaise réponse,
La grande croix en haut à gauche,
c'est là où 2000 étudiants
ont donné exactement la même mauvaise réponse.
Si deux étudiants dans une classe de 100
donnent la même mauvaise réponse,
on ne le remarquerait jamais
Mais quand 2000 étudiants donnent la même mauvaise réponse,
c'est dur de ne pas le voir.
Alors Andrew et ses étudiants
ont examiné certains de ces travaux,
ont compris la cause de l'erreur,
et ont ensuite écrit un message d'erreur spécifique
pour tous les étudiants
qui avaient fait cette faute,
ce qui veut dire que les étudiants qui ont fait la même erreur
auront maintenant un retour personnalisé
leur disant comment corriger leur erreur bien plus efficacement.
Cette personnalisation est donc quelque chose qu'on peut construire
grâce aux grands nombres mis en jeu.
La personnalisation est peut-être
une des plus grandes opportunités ici,
parce qu'elle nous donne la possibilité
de résoudre un problème vieux de 30 ans.
Le chercheur en éducation Benjamin Bloom, en 1984,
a posé ce qu'il appelle le problème 2 sigma,
qu'il a observé en étudiant trois populations.
La première est la population qui a étudié dans un cours magistral.
La deuxième est une population d'étudiants qui ont étudié
dans un cours magistral,
mais avec une approche fondée sur la maîtrise,
les étudiants ne pouvant pas passer au sujet suivant
avant d'avoir démontré qu'ils maîtrisaient le précédent.
Enfin, il y avait une population d'étudiants
auxquels on enseignait de manière individuelle grâce à un tuteur.
L'enseignement fondé sur la maîtrise donnait des scores meilleurs
d'un écart-type, ou un sigma,
que les cours magistraux
et le tutorat individuel donne une amélioration
2 sigma sur les résultats.
Pour comprendre ce que ça veut dire,
observons le cours magistral,
et prenons la performance médiane comme seuil.
Dans un cours magistral,
la moitié des étudiants sont donc au-dessus de ce niveau et la moitié sont en dessous.
Dans le tutorat individuel,
98 % des étudiants vont être au-dessus de ce seuil.
Imaginez alors qu'on puisse enseigner de telle sorte que 98 % de nos étudiants
soient au-dessus de la moyenne.
D'où, le problème 2 sigma.
Parce que nous n'avons pas les moyens, en tant que société,
de fournir à chaque étudiant un tuteur humain individuel.
Mais peut-être que nous avons les moyens de donner à chaque étudiant
un ordinateur ou un smartphone.
La question est donc, comment peut-on utiliser la technologie
pour passer de la partie gauche du graphique, de la courbe bleue,
au côté droit du graphique avec la courbe verte ?
La maîtrise est facile à atteindre avec un ordinateur
parce qu'un ordinateur peut, sans se fatiguer,
montrer la même vidéo 5 fois.
Ça ne le fatigue pas non plus d'évaluer le même travail plusieurs fois
nous l'avons constaté dans de nombreux exemples que je vous ai montrés.
Et même la personnalisation
est une chose qu'on commence à voir
que ce soit par le parcours personnalisé
ou par le retour personnalisé que nous vous avons montré.
Le but ici est d'essayer, de pousser
et de voir à quel point on peut s'approcher de la courbe verte.
Si c'est si formidable, les universités sont-elles désormais obsolètes ?
Mark Twain le pensait sans doute.
Il a dit que " La faculté est un endroit où les notes de cours d'un professeur
vont directement dans les notes que prennent les étudiants
sans passer par leurs cerveaux respectifs."
(Rires)
Je ne suis pas d'accord avec Mark Twain.
Je pense que ce dont il se plaignait n'était pas
les universités mais plutôt les cours magistraux
qui représentent tellement de temps dans tellement d'universités.
Remontons plus loin encore, à Plutarque,
qui disait que "L'esprit n'est pas un vase qu'il faut remplir
mais du bois qu'il faut enflammer."
Nous devrions peut-être passer moins de temps à l'université
à remplir l'esprit de nos étudiants du contenu
de nos cours, et plus de temps à enflammer leur créativité,
leur imagination et leur aptitudes à résoudre des problèmes
en dialoguant vraiment avec eux.
Alors comment fait-on cela ?
Nous le faisons par l'apprentissage actif en cours.
Beaucoup d'études ont été faites, dont celle-ci,
montrant que si on a recours à un apprentissage actif,
en interagissant avec les étudiants en cours,
toutes les performances sont améliorées :
assiduité, implication et apprentissage
mesurés par un test standardisé.
Vous voyez, par exemple, que le taux de réussite
double quasiment dans cette expérience précise.
C'est peut-être à ça que nous devrions consacrer notre temps à l'université.
Pour résumer, si on pouvait offrir la meilleure éducation
à tout le monde gratuitement dans le monde entier,
qu'est-ce que cela ferait ? Trois choses.
D'abord, ça établirait l'éducation comme droit humain fondamental,
et tous ceux dans le monde
qui ont la capacité et la motivation
pourraient acquérir les compétences dont ils ont besoin
pour rendre meilleure leur vie, celle de leur famille
et celle de leurs communautés.
Deuxièmement, ça permettrait l'apprentissage tout au long de la vie.
Il est dommage que pour tant de gens,
l'apprentissage cesse quand ils quittent le lycée ou la fac.
En rendant ce formidable contenu disponible,
on pourrait apprendre quelque chose de nouveau
chaque fois qu'on le veut,
que ce soit juste pour élargir nos esprits
ou pour changer nos vies.
Et enfin, ça permettrait une vague d'innovation,
parce qu'on peut trouver du talent exceptionnel n'importe où.
Peut-être que le prochain Albert Einstein ou le prochain Steve Jobs
vit quelque part dans un village isolé en Afrique.
Et si nous pouvions offrir à cette personne une éducation,
elle serait en mesure de proposer la prochaine grande idée
et faire du monde un endroit meilleur pour nous tous.
Merci beaucoup.
[Applaudissements]